[Applause]
ranking all the guest characters in
teken notis lues kyum noctis is a
character from The Final Fantasy series
and one of the guest characters included
in Tekken
seven his gameplay mechanics are adapted
to fit the Tekken fighting system making
him a distinctive character to play one
yes who went for the blocking k for it
okay that's the game you have play all
three floor have been broken by
[Music]
Bryan that was so he was
prar pissing our pants yet negan's
inclusion in Tekken 7 added a surprising
and unexpected crossover element to the
game he retains his Persona and moves
that from The Walking Dead easy peasy
lemon squeezy
bead
you you better be joking he wields his
iconic weapon Lucille which is a barbed
wire covered baseball
bat his appearance in Tekken has been
well received by fans of both Tekken and
The Walking Dead series get there's the
followup here this is going to be big
damage a grip of damage right now good
combo back to the wall strings are
coming out what has Chad got for him
oh oh he missed the followup okay okay
it's not done yet it's not
over oh nice block nice oh you know I
saw her in the corner of my eyes they
let
[Music]
go bring it on I'll destroy you all
geese brings a distinct and familiar
style to teken S making him a fan
favorite among those who enjoyed the SNK
series
his inclusion adds to the roster
diversity and showcases the rich history
of fighting game
characters he is a formidable character
with a diverse set of powerful high
damage moves and
combos that'll do it arson is eliminated
from Evil con we be moving
[Music]
on
akuma's addition was significant because
it brought together two of the most
popular and influential fighting game
franchises his inclusion in Tekken 7
added an exciting new dimension to the
game as his 2D fighting game moves and
mechanics were integrated into the 3D
fighting World detect
oh God God fu quickness he became a
formidable character in the game and a
favorite for players who were familiar
with him from Street Fighter say that
Mark I want to see my God look at the
help the demon the demon let's go I
can't believe what we're seeing look at
the life Barb oh my goodness he probably
has a sliver right he might have
a oh my God oh my let's
[Music]
go
gon's inclusion in Tekken 3 was somewhat
of a novelty and a fun addition to the
roster gone is actually from a popular
mananga series in Japan of the same
name while he's not a highly competitive
character he's beloved by fans for his
humorous and unconventional fighting
style
[Music]
you
win so do you agree with our list which
guest character do you want to include
in Tekken 8 my
mother leave your comments below and
make sure to subscribe to ooo
TV
[Music]
he